[Music]
hello everyone
and welcome back to the road to 2000 as
always my name is caleb denby
and tonight i am going to be taking you
through the skilling open
finals and apologies if i'm not
pronouncing that right these
norwegian things uh they're tough for me
as are
many many pronunciation questions um
and of course the finals took place
while the final of the finals took place
on magnus carlsen the world champion's
birthday
and it was of course between wesley so
online rapid player extraordinaire
and of course magnus himself and let's
just not waste any time and get into it
here
we have our games uh that i want to look
at
and to start with in these finals i
actually want to look at a game
that magnus carlsen won the
story of this last match that they
played uh
of course the the format of the
tournament is there were two
sort of mini matches that the players
played they split the first one
and split the second one so it went on
to
tie breaks which wesley so of course did
manage to win
but i wanted to focus on a few games in
particular in that last
up that we're really decided in one of
my favorite openings
the karo khan so let's see how the
players each approached
these positions so to start with wesley
has white here
and we see him go for e4 of course c6
d4 d5 e5 and then in this game
magnus chose the move bishop to f5 so
this is the main
line of the advanced variation in the
caro khan white
takes this extra space with the pawn on
e5
and black does what black set out to do
and develop the bishop
outside the pawn chain and aim for sort
of a quote unquote
better french why is it a better french
well because the bishop is outside the
pawn chain
instead of passive behind the pawn chain
and there are many many ways
that players with the white pieces have
tried to play against this idea
right now actually the most popular uh
is this move
h4 this is sort of the trendy idea
this is what people are doing as of late
and we saw this move uh appear quite a
few times
including in numerous games in the st
louis rapid and blitz
this is sort of everywhere this has sort
of become the most
topical line at the top level against
the the keracon
and black has been responding with this
move h5 and then you end up
in this position uh generally
after e6 and bishop g5 and queen b6
and who knows what's going on here these
positions
are super crazy but that's not what we
see in this game
and perhaps i should take this as a sign
that this h4 variation is dying out
because i do think players with the
black pieces
have sort of begun to figure this one
out and have managed to defuse
uh most of the problems that uh that
arise there
so wesley picked uh sort of another
sideline
that we don't see too often against the
carrow and that's this move
knight to d2 and i'm actually going to
flip the board we're going to take a
look
from magnus's perspective now because he
was the victor in this game
so what's the point of knight d2 why
this strange looking developing move
to uh to start with well the answer is
is quite simple uh black is aiming to
play e6
and c5 as black often does in openings
like the french and of course the
opening that we are actually in the
advanced keracon
this is the main plan for black to
challenge the the center of the board
here you play c5
you attack d4 a little bit you can
develop naturally with knight c6
queen b6 these are the common plans
for black so if white had instead
continued with perhaps a more natural
move knight f3
we would likely see e6 something like
bishop e2
and something like c5 is the the main
line stuff
for black here so what wesley does with
knight d2
is he says that after the move e6 i'm
going to come
first with knight b3 and challenge this
c5 square
and now we're going to see that magnus
takes a really interesting approach
to uh to challenging this idea
first of all he he plays the normal move
with knight d7
you want to build back up control over
c5
and you're willing to not develop this
knight out to c6
putting it instead on the c7 square in
order to uh to achieve this goal
and so magnus plants the knight on d7
which is the normal starting point
for black uh just challenging c5
white continues with normal development
now knight f3 the idea of knight d2 to
b3
doesn't mean we're still we're not going
to still develop out naturally on the
king side with knight f3
uh and then to continue here magnus
differs from the main line theory a
little bit
and we'll see that he has a very
specific idea
in mind with this magnus plays the move
h6
and this seems like a kind of a waste of
time right why are we playing the move
h6
well it's just of course giving this
bishop some some extra space to breathe
it's also controlling the g5 square
which can be relevant sometimes
but importantly it's not the natural
developing move knight e7 and this is
the move that is actually the most
common
and that's uh players with the black
pieces uh
generally tend to do uh matteo says what
about
a5 after knight g3 uh i i think you mean
knight b3
and we'll see that a5 is actually
definitely on magnus's mind
but um yeah why not knight e7 first and
this is the
the idea that sort of struck me as
strange in this game that magnus was
playing
generally everybody just develops this
knight out to e7 and then the game
continues but we'll see that
magnus leaves this knight on g8 for a
very particular reason
and that reason is after h6 bishop e2
magnus does want to play this move a5
and now this is very much
uncharted waters here this exact
position
i think has never really been reached at
the top level and
we'll see what magnus has in mind so
white should always respond to this move
with a4
that's the short answer black's idea of
playing a5 a4 against the knight on b3
is very very typical really in any
position where there's a knight on b3
you can consider pushing the a pawn
forward to try to shake it loose
and white's response is natural you want
to play a4
and we're going to see that white has a
very
strong plan against this move a5 and
this is why it doesn't appear too often
but in this first game magnus actually
had a great pr
preventative move that sort of stops
white's plan altogether
and that move is bishop to b for check
and this is the reason why magnus left
this knight on
on the g8 square magnus wanted to play
this move a5
and by leaving this knight on g8 magnus
has this extra idea of playing bishop b4
check
that wouldn't otherwise be there had
magnus played the move knight e7
why does this matter well we'll have to
check in on uh
the follow-up game to to really
understand
what the difference is but for now just
trust me this was
brilliant for magnus and i will give you
a hint why
bishop d2 is actually not going to be a
great move for white to try to
prove the advantage that classic
principle that says
when you have less space you should
trade pieces very much holds true here
and so
magnus would just trade the pieces on uh
on the d2 square for example bishop d2
and something like queen d2 continue
with knight e7
and it's simply going to be a good
version of similar positions that black
often gets why is it a good version
well black's pieces are no longer
stepping on each other's toes as the
bishop and knight often do in this
opening
and black is going to continue with an
eventual c5 and total equality here
so wesley tries really the only try for
an advantage
which is c3 keeping pieces on the board
and
forcing black to work a little bit
harder to to complete development
so magnus comes all the way back to f8
and obviously to a beginner
and even to to myself at first this
looks kind of moronic
by by magnus carlson like what on god's
green earth is going on here your
bishop's on f8
so you play bishop b4 and bishop f8 and
now it's white's turn
and white makes seemingly an improving
move bringing the pawn to c3
supporting the center and getting this
pawn off of a square where it was
targeted by the bishop
what's not to like for white well i'm
curious if any of you
uh can can sort of tell me why
moving this pawn to c3 is so favorable
to magnus
i'm curious what the chat thinks about
this maneuver what is magnus's point
with
drawing this pawn out to c3 there's
actually a couple really useful ideas
a couple of really useful ideas here
creating a weakness on the light squares
uh says
mathis in the chat and that's part of
the the reason why this pawn moves to c3
we'll see a little bit later on that
magnus is going to bring the queen out
to b6
and this is very much in line with the
plan of ham of targeting
this knight on b3 trying to push it
around a little bit that's what we
wanted to do with a5
and now later it's been weakened a
little bit with this pawn push to c3
and black can apply just a little bit of
pressure but that's actually not the
main point
or at least i'm arguing that's not the
main point magnus had in mind
what is the main point well by drawing
this pawn out to c3
actually very crucially magnus has
closed down this dark square diagonal
now that doesn't seem
like a big thing but when you play this
pawn out to a5
you are in a sense giving yourself and
your opponent a little bit of a weakness
to worry about
and with this knight already on b3 black
is gonna have some very serious trouble
defending this pawn if for example this
pawn we're back on c2
and just say bishop d2 queenie one
ever appeared on the board it's going to
be very difficult to defend this pawn
without playing something like b6 which
maybe isn't the most comfortable right
we're already short on squares we don't
really want to take away the b6 square
from our pieces
as well so magnus
number one is ready to target this night
now and number two
is shutting down this diagonal and is
that worth a move this early on in the
opening
to my eyes it looked like no when i
first saw this game when i was first
analyzing it i was like what is magnus
doing this is
sort of ridiculous but we'll see that
the game gets to a point
where wesley kind of runs out of ideas
and ends up giving this tempo back by
playing c3 to c4
anyways so this is why i wanted to start
with this game
really interesting opening ideas by the
world champion here
uh playing you know seemingly principle
breaking moves
but with rather deep uh middle game
purposes behind them right
magnus wastes this time but we'll see
that wesley ends up sort of without a
middle game plan
and that's a very very valuable thing to
uh to have
so the game does continue wesley plays
kingside castles of course
and now we do see the natural knight e7
so
for all our waiting with this knight on
g8 we managed to play bishop b4 and
bishop back to
back to f8 absolutely brilliant um
h3 and i said that jokingly but also not
jokingly
it's tough to tell uh h3 and now bishop
h7
once again due to the lack of space
black is
sort of having to do some gymnastics to
get these pieces into the game uh knight
f5 is going to follow
so bishop d2 and we see now that perhaps
it is very useful
that we're not worrying right now about
this a5 pawn
and magnus does continue with queen b6
now
this queen itself is a little bit tied
down and this knight is just a little
bit
loose and this is how strong players
manage to win
in rapid games and blitz games
especially they just give you
one sort of annoying weakness that you
have to keep track of they make loose
pieces in their opponent's camp
and then they sort of wait for the
tactics to come and
we'll see if they do in this case
wesley tries to move knight to e1
perhaps paving the way
for some king side advances magnus just
continues out now with knight i5
if g4 knight h4 is the response and it's
sort of
uh known at this point that um
that this move is just a little bit more
weakening than it's worth especially
with black having not castled
uh one more comment on the opening that
i forgot to mention and then i promise
we'll get to the rest of the game
but there was a comment in the chat that
h6 is sort of
uh sort of the move that you would
expect a beginner to play
and yes it's with the idea of dropping
this bishop back to h7
but i should very much mention the main
line which goes 97
kingside castles and then g5 for black
so
h6 yes gives this bishop square uh space
and that's the
justification that we saw in the game
but also it's it's with this idea
of uh expanding on the king's side if
black castles a bit too early
so multi-purpose move that h6 uh
wanted to just advise you guys that that
plan exists so queen b6 91
and now knight f5 and now wesley
continues with bishop d3
we see bishop b7 completing development
for
magnus and now queen c2 and
queen c2 does actually make a threat the
threat now is g4
and this bishop is actually under
defended here on h7
so we see magnus making the awkward move
bishop g6
now once again we see magnus sort of
wasting some time
but bishop h7 bishop g6 was sort of uh
met by bishop e2 bishop d3 so it's not
a huge waste of time as it may seem now
if g4
magnus can still just simply play knight
h4 and this is not a problem at all
and here is the position where perhaps
wesley finds himself
without a a reasonable plan
right there's plenty of moves that white
can play
white can play knight back to f3 uh
white can play g4 white
can play rook c1 b1 or d1 really
whichever you choose
uh white can just pass with knight with
king h1
but what's the point right what is the
point of any of these moves
for white magnus is going to continue to
make improving moves
castle king's side bring the rook to the
queen's side continue out with c5 black
has very clearly defined plans
and very easy ways to improve the
position whereas with white
you know these moves their chess moves
but
it's a little bit difficult to tell
what it's it's all leading up to are you
going for some sort of kingside advance
that's going to allow peace trades on
this diagonal now are you going
for the move c4 what are you doing
and in response to this sort of dilemma
wesley just plays the move c4
immediately
and now we'll see that this move is
actually going to be wrong
number one positionally this isn't that
bad of an idea
uh players with the white pieces often
go for this break of c4 when black is
sort of just
hunkering down with their big solid
triangle of defense
but here we'll see that there is a
tactical issue with it
so magnus starts with d take c4 and now
queen takes c4
and i would like you guys at home to try
and find the tactic here
black to move and get a good position
what do you guys have
mateo says this bishop h7 knight f5 id
an idea
i assume he's saying that before i show
showed that that happened in the game
so yes it was magnus's idea in fact
hello hiroshi hello hello black to move
here
and get an excellent position
and yeah vinnie has the right idea here
you just capture
on d4 and this is what i mean when i say
this is how strong players win rapid
games and blitz games
right all the way back here magnus plays
queen b6
and this knight is loose doesn't matter
doesn't matter here
it doesn't matter for for any of these
moves but now all of a sudden
knight takes d4 and this loose piece is
dropping
off if queen takes d4 which was played
in the game we see queen takes b3
perhaps the more natural move knight
takes d4 might be something
that uh wesley missed uh
sorry something that wesley might have
missed is that knight takes e5
is a powerful response in this case and
now
if queen c3 for example there's bishop
b4
forcing the queen away from the defense
of the knight
and magnus will be sort of crushing here
cruising
so instead queen takes d4 queen takes b3
bishop takes g6 f takes g6 is in fact
sort of fracturing black's pawn
structure but we'll see now that black
does just have
the extra pawn so it would be
very very easy to look at this game and
say yeah
okay you know black was equal out of the
opening and then wesley blundered with
c4 and magnus got a good position
but i spent so much time in the opening
because i think it's
uh really sort of a brilliant game by
by magnus here to put wesley in this
position where
you just don't have a clear path to
improvement and that is sort of
your worst nightmare in any middle game
if you don't see how you're going to
improve your pieces
and even worse if you do see how your
opponent is going to improve their
pieces
then you know you're sort of in a tough
spot even if objectively your position
shouldn't be that bad
and that's what happened to wesley here
there just wasn't a clear path to
improving white's
position so wesley goes for sort of this
risky move c4
and it just doesn't really work out now
notably the game is
is far from over here black is up a pawn
but does have many weaknesses on the
king's side
which should be pretty pretty evident
and
white does have a little bit of a lead
in development white is castled already
and black has some work to do before the
rooks get in the game
before these loose pieces like the
knight on d7 like this queen on b3
are totally safe so wesley tries this
move queen e4 in the game
to challenge this g6 pawn but this just
allows magnus to castle king's side
queen g6 would be responded to by knight
takes e5
uh bishop takes h6 though was now the
idea
by wesley and of course this is just a a
drawing attempt i believe if magnus were
to capture
i have little doubt that wesley would go
for queen g6 and queen h6
with of course a standard perpetual
check
but that's not what magnus has in mind
so magnus plays the move rook
f5 instead rook f5 just interfering with
this queen
and actually returning the pawn now of
course
returning the pawn isn't totally the
truth here because
this pawn is still going to be very very
weak and in fact could be captured
immediately
but instead what uh magnus goes for the
better move which is
queen d5 better in my opinion at least
in a practical sense
uh wesley sort of jumps at the
opportunity to simplify things a little
bit
this is something that that wesley
usually does very well
when things start to get out of hands
you'll often see him go
into sort of damage control mode and say
all right
i'm just going to draw this game all
right you've you've done enough magnus
you've shown me enough in this opening
you've got the draw i i'm ready to end
the game
so that's why we see queen takes d5 i
think it's very much
a stylistic decision that you would
expect from wesley so
uh magnus now captures with the e pawn
sort of trying to keep
uh the pawn islands to a minimum of
course this is an a strategic idea
that's pretty well known
it's better to have one pawn island than
two pawn islands just because it gives
you
less or fewer weaker pawns in general so
e takes d5
and now we see the move f4 by
magnus carlsen and i want to ask you
guys
if you can find magnus carlsen's next
move
and the justification for it i think
it's
pretty easy to find this move it's a
pretty natural move but it's not so easy
to uh to find the justification because
white has a pretty tempting move in
response
as well so black to move here chat what
do you guys think
yeah f4 by wesley not by magnus my
apologies
so yeah mateo has the idea the idea is
g5
but why does g5 work
uh why does g5 work
well i guess first the question is why
doesn't it work and then the the
question
after that is why does it work anyways
right
white has a very tempting move in
response to g5 that
must be calculated before going for this
move
very tempting response is available to
uh
to wesley
all right nobody has it so let me ask
you chatroom what are you going to do
in response to g4 the rook retreating
e6 the knight moving and f5
making big glorious pawn chain big
glorious pawn chain there
scary stuff scary stuff it's big it's
glorious
it's terrifying so what is you're gonna
what is going to be
your response to the move e6 and g4
yeah connect four wesley is threatening
to connect four
are you gonna let him do it
are you just gonna let wesley connect
four like that
winning the game like you you've
connected three it's gonna be a while
before you can turn that into four
or maybe not that long i don't know now
i'm just playing connect four
this is perhaps a better game
throw in bishop c5
perhaps that's a little bit too bold i'm
not sure where exactly
you are throwing in bishop c5
big and mighty you've heard those words
before don't understand the reference
so magnus actually has a a really great
exchange sacrifice
in mind here and it's it's worth keeping
track of these things
right i think the exchange sacrifice may
be the single most useful
positional idea that uh that sort of
exists
in chess right this is sort of the
bare minimum you can sacrifice uh
in order to to change the position
favorably right
you know sacrificing a piece to improve
your position is oftentimes just not
worth it right pieces are just too good
you can't
give your opponent something for nothing
but sacrificing an exchange
it's sometimes debatably not even a
sacrifice right if it's a position where
the rooks aren't doing well
and where your minor piece can shine
then it's
sort of just a favorable trade for the
side losing the rook right if your rook
was bad
and the minor piece is good then why not
make this trade
and on top of that magnus is going to be
able to make
this trade this exchange sacrifice and
completely wipe up wesley so's center at
the same time
so always be on the lookout for these
types of exchange sacrifices it really
is a
super super useful way to just entirely
change the dynamic of the position
because on the surface it looks like
these pawns bad
these pawns not bad these pawns not
going anywhere
you know why wouldn't white be better
here for example let's say
magnus has played a move like rook a to
f8 right
and all of a sudden g4 and and mac or
wesley is winning the game
so let's say like a slightly better move
like knight c5
once again g4 is going to come stroke
will have to retreat
uh and i don't know even like takes even
just king here
and like i would prefer white i would
very much prefer white
in this position if it uh sort of came
to this point right these pawns are just
scarier than these pawns
and i have double g pawns that i have to
worry about
so what does magnus do well he just
changes the character of the position
entirely with the move g5 and he does so
very favorably here
wesley does continue with this move e6
knight c5
and now g4 uh but now we are going to
see
the point of magnus's idea which is to
simply capture on
f4 not allowing white the opportunity to
connect the pawns
so beautifully and just sacrificing this
rook
wesley does accept the sacrifice and now
we see
magnus is able to capture this bishop on
e3
and what is magnus uh getting for for
this exchange well for the moment he is
getting a pawn although this pawn on e3
may potentially die
but what else is he getting well now
with the dark squared bishop off the
board this is the color complex that
magnus is going to look to dominate
and this is what you should really do
whenever you have
an unopposed bishop of any kind you look
to dominate
on that color of square especially when
your opponent has
a rook for it so here we're going to see
that while these pawns may look
threatening
magnus is going to set up a position
where he's just able to easily
neutralize these pawns
using the control of the dark squares in
front of them
wesley continued with the move rook f4
bishop f6
is a very natural start applying
pressure down this diagonal
now knight c2 by wesley is desperately
trying to capture this pawn
e2 by magnus rook f2 by by wesley
really trying to capture this pawn but
this is the move that sort of now
entirely loses the game
outright wesley had to try to go for
more activity on this side of the board
something like rook g4 but
it's a very tough position and black is
significantly better
so what's wrong with rook f2 well it
just loses the game tactically
unfortunately
if you want to try to find the move for
black here go ahead and pause otherwise
here it is
just d4 and this is a pretty simple one
that i'm sure you guys have seen before
rook takes e2 and d3 attacks two pieces
at the same time uh devastating stuff so
now rather than be down
the exchange magnus has essentially the
same position
except with two pieces for for the rook
instead of one
so now just clearly winning for black
uh you cannot take this knight by the
way because of the bishop fork so rookie
one instead
and now knight takes a4 magnus just
starts cleaning up the pawns
knight takes b2 as well and now this
knight comes
all the way back to d5 and puts itself
on the e7 square like i said total
dark square domination is what magnus is
after and that's what he achieves by
putting the pieces here
these pawns are completely immobilized
double blockaded
and this knight even pressures the the
backward pawn on f5
just as an added little bonus
uh king g4 defends the pawn and magnus
just starts pushing now
and there's really no response to this
uh rook d1 was tried but now b4
can you guess magnus's idea uh rook 87
and now b3 rook d8 check gets one set of
rooks off the board
yeah but now b2 king f4 and
upon seeing the move knight d5 check
wesley so
just went ahead and resigned the game
why does wesley still resign well if you
go king e4
i'll simply make a queen and win your
rook
and if you don't go king e4 i will
simply
win the game some other way how am i
gonna win the game i'm gonna push this
pawn
up the board and make a second queen uh
or if
you know just make a queen so that was
the game
uh between wesley and magnus where i
think magnus actually took the lead he
struck first blood
in that uh in this final match on his
own birthday so great for magnus
striking first blood and let's recap
what happened
we see magnus play this slightly weird
h6
but it's not that weird black has this
idea of g5 but then
sort of strangely goes a5 a4 and then
gives this bishop check and retreats
back to f8
and what we saw is that this pawn was
drawn out to c3
seemingly insignificant surface level
this
is just ridiculous play by magnus
carlson but we'll see
because of this wesley was really left
without this middle
game plan that he sort of really
desperately needed
uh now to sort of counter this idea i
want to look at another game
by wesley so and perhaps you'll find the
opening to be a little bit
more familiar with some some new ideas
being introduced
so let's see how wesley improves upon
that first game
and we'll see if this bishop f8 to b4
idea was really so dangerous
by magnus carlsen we once again see the
carol khan on the board
e5 bishop f5 now knight f3 e6
and bishop e2 so how does this differ
from the previous game well wesley now
goes for the mainline stuff
knight f3 bishop e2 sometimes called the
short variation
this is how uh you know
they've been playing against the carol
khan for some years now this is
sort of seen as the main line of old and
magnus once again repeats this move h6
and i think this is what wesley was
banking on uh magnus
if you guys have been following closely
whenever he does play the kerocon he's
one of those guys that sort of just
always goes 9797 and
and doesn't necessarily play c5 that
quickly and i think he does this just to
avoid
a lot of the main theory and just get
some type of position that he can play
so h6 and i'm willing to bet that wesley
was sort of banking on this
so we see kingside castles by wesley
and now we see the move knight e7 by
magnus
now what had happened what would have
happened had we seen
knight to d7 by magnus as in the
previous game
well unfortunately for magnus things are
not the same
as in the previous game you can very
much expect knight b
uh to d2 and then you know perhaps
we we see some move like a5 once again
sort of anticipating knight p3 a4 by
white
let's say bishop b4 but now after knight
b3
you have not successfully drawn my pawn
to c3 wesley has
preempted this by castling the king
earlier on
and avoiding this nasty little check
that draws this pawn out to c3
and so here white is just simply better
why is white better well white has all
the benefits of the last position that
we looked at
and without this really crucial downside
of putting the pawn on c3
by the way don't even think about
putting this knight on e7 because then
c3 would in fact trap your bishop
and black's best move here is bishop f8
so in this case
this is not some genius maneuver by
black this would just be improving
white's position by getting this knight
to b3
not even drawing this pawn out to c3 in
the process so
effectively by going for this move order
wesley has successfully avoided magnus's
entire idea
and i really wanted to highlight these
two games because i think this
really super interesting back and forth
between the two players
this interesting little discussion on
the kero khan and this particular line
probably went largely unnoticed by by a
lot of people
so this seemingly you know random choice
of
of you know not going for knight d2 to
b3 it's
it's easy to say wesley didn't go for
this because the first game didn't go
well for him
so we reverted back to the main line but
i think and this is just a guess on my
part
wesley was anticipating magnus would
play in a similar style
and wesley understood why that first
game went wrong for him and so by
understanding
his first game's mistake he was able to
improve very very significantly in the
second game
and that is the type of thing that will
win you matches against the world
champion when you can sort of improve
on the fly like that understand why your
first game went so badly
understand that it wasn't just that you
blundered with c4 but that this move c3
was actually quite annoying to deal with
so that
is the critical improvement and that is
why i'm talking about wesley so against
magnus carlsen tonight because i found
this opening exchange
so so interesting now of course the rest
of the game is interesting as well so
let's jump to that
knight bd2 now knight d7 by magnus and
we see all the same plans as a previous
game
as the previous game but this little
exchange
has not occurred there's no bishop b4
back to f8 and there's no pawn on c3
so wesley now continues with knight b3
magnus retreats the bishop back to h7 so
far
so good seemingly identical to the
previous game
bishop d2 as in the previous game queen
b6
now wesley plays this move h3 which is
perhaps hinting at the move g4 a little
bit later on
but in reality i think it's sort of just
a clever waiting move
what is wesley waiting for well he's
waiting for magnus to interfere with
this bishop with the move knight g6
or or knight f5 uh in the game magnus
does choose
knight g6 and then all of a sudden we
see the move queen e1
and compared to the previous position
where wesley couldn't find
a plan to improve and had to go for the
shaky c4 which ends up losing the game
for him
here wesley says why is your pawn on a5
i'm going to attack that pawn
and then win that pawn and then win the
game
and this is just impossible to stop now
for black
so this in my opinion is where wesley so
got the better of magnus carlsen in this
match
magnus perhaps had the more interesting
opening ideas to start with
but then wesley's ability to adapt on
the fly turned out to be really really
useful wesley adapted
to magnus's approach he found a way to
refute the idea
or prevent the idea altogether and then
he just simply executed the plan
and like the professional that wesley is
once he had a grip on the position he
just never let go
of course black isn't forced to lose a
pawn here there is the move bishop b4
in this particular position and of
course leslie is not going to be playing
the move c3 here
but now can force a weakness in black's
camp with the move bishop b4
black can and should try to trade the
queens
but now after ab4 we'll see this pawn on
b4
is simply uh doomed to fall
there's no way to actually keep this guy
on the board
as we'll see after just very natural
play by wesley
first and foremost wesley i think is a
little bit worried about some of the
pressure on this e5 pawn
and sees no reason to leave this bishop
uncontested against c2
so starts with bishop d3 and then
already magnus goes for c5 which
is very much the the beginning of of the
end here
it was already a tough position for
black and black is already going to be
much better
for example had magnus played a more use
a more normal move like kingside castles
white's going to play a5
rook a4 rook takes b4 and best of luck
to you
to stop this idea uh really best of luck
to you i i don't know how
you are going to keep this pawn on the
board against this very simple idea
uh so c5 instead it's a more active idea
maybe objectively it's a little bit
worse than the previous idea of just
castling
but you know it's it's gonna be a game
still so
wesley captures on c5 magnus captures on
c5
and wesley takes back on c5
notably i don't think you can really do
anything else here
there's no way to win this e5 pawn
especially with the bishop here
so the trade makes sense uh
now black tries to move rook a5
but tactically this just isn't going to
work out uh there's bishop b5 check to
start with for wesley
and why is your rook on a5 it's not like
it's attacking my c5 pawn
king e7 was the continuation rook fe1
rook c8 and then wesley comes up with a
pretty nice idea
to uh to maintain the pawns here on the
queen's side
so white to move and maintain the
structure see what you guys
can come up with here and by the way
just want to say there there's another
idea that is perhaps even better than
what wesley played
but for aesthetic reasons i really do
prefer what what wesley decided
to play
this is in fact life peter brankovin
but i am doing a bit more talking
tonight and less chat interaction
then normal but here i am talking to you
guys in the chat room
so yeah you guys have it completely
right perhaps you've seen the game
but c3 is the nice idea for wesley to
maintain everything on the queen side
and just keep a winning advantage uh the
secondary idea
that is perhaps even better is this move
knight d4
and it has the same exact idea this pawn
is just uncapturable
thanks to knight b3 which would fork
both of the rooks so
in the game though c3 played instead and
i really do like this for aesthetic
reasons
black captures on c3 notably if you take
this
of course this is not ideal
uh so black takes and then wesley just
plays b4
uh c3 just gets the b4 pawn out of the
way
so that wesley can occupy that square
himself and keep the nice little
structure
on the queen side of the board and now
uh
magnus plays rook a to a8 we see rook a
to c1
knight f4 and this pawn is in fact going
to fall as well
bishop b4 on the board a5 now f6
h4 uh just a little bit of maneuvering
on the king's side magnus is trying to
open things up a little bit
to find some counter play over here
because he knows he's just going to get
rolled on the queen side eventually
and wesley just plays a nice little
preventative move to keep black from
taking
all this extra space g5 is played
anyways
but now g3 knight g6
and wesley starts taking stuff and
by the way i will say that perhaps
wesley's technique in this position
wasn't the you know the most accurate of
all time
by opening up this h file it actually
turns out that black has a lot of
counter play
and perhaps had chances to to even save
the game
um but it wasn't meant to be for magnus
and i should say that this one i think
was played in the tiebreakers and so it
was
sort of a five minute game rather than
the 15 minutes that they were playing
uh previously but okay with this opening
of the h file black is now going to get
some counter play so perhaps the move h5
was a bit more responsible
by wesley but now after takes takes
knight h2
95 yeah all of a sudden there there are
some checkmating threats
uh alive and that goes to show the
resilience of magnus carlsen
you know he gets totally demolished in
the opening it's just losing on the
queen side
and then out of nowhere there are
checkmating threats um
rook c to e3 was wesley's choice in the
game
and perhaps again it's time to play some
defense bishop f1 to g2 for example
but rick's e3 instead rook h8 what else
now f3 turns out to be wesley's idea to
try and take back some light squares
uh but now black does find a really nice
tactic to keep keep himself in the game
here
magnus plays rook takes h2 and knight
takes f3
and now with this black very much is
back in the game
rook f3 bishop f3 should be played and
was played
and now uh wesley finds a nice idea of
playing c6
so magnus won some material back there
on the king's side
thanks to all these checkmating threats
but now after c6 it's sort of a
thin line to walk for magnus to still
save the game why is it such a thin line
well
white's pawns are further away from the
kings and white's pawns are also further
advanced and
that's sort of as simple as it gets in
the game magnus plays the move d4
and this is in fact the sort of final
losing
move after this black is just out of the
game no way to save it
turns out though that black would have
still been in the game
had he played the move he takes c6 which
is pretty counterintuitive to just sort
of relent and allow these pawns to
become past
but what's the point the point is after
check you can
check this king seemingly randomly into
the middle of the board
otherwise you'll repeat and by drawing
this king out
to uh to the b3 square
hold on i'm doing this backwards uh
let's say rook h8
and then king e7 bring the king to the
queen site then i forgot to include the
moves
uh a6 or sorry b5
king d6 a6 just improving for white and
only now
after g4 a7 do you draw the king out to
the center of the board
so i mixed up my lines there and the
point is now you have this move d4
check sort of out of nowhere this is the
only resource for black to stay in the
game
what's the point well you're going to
take this bishop
and go rook a2 and from my analysis i
think this reckon game
should be a draw although it's it's
going to still be
a pretty narrow path for uh for black to
follow for example after c7
king takes c7 would actually lose the
game instead you do have to insert
this check and draw the king out to c4
before you take
why do you have to do that well after
takes takes
takes for example would lose to rookie 7
so king b7 is the only idea
and then here it turns out it's very
very relevant
that's uh rook a3 is first of all not in
the position
and second of all uh
white would have rook e3 in response in
order to to win the game so for example
had we played uh check and check
even this would be losing for black
because here
after king b7 rook e3 is good enough to
win the game
you defend this pawn white comes and
takes this guy and then wins
so how does black draw well you repeat
forever and ever and ever
until eventually white gets bored and
you take on c7
and now king b7 does turn out to be
enough for a draw
because this pawn is indefensible and
black is in front of
the apon so all of that is to say even
though
wesley's a genius magnus is a genius too
magnus found his way back into the game
but this stuff is just impossible to
find in blitz unless you sort of luck
your way into it
and magnus was not lucky on this
birthday of his
so the game did not continue with b take
c6 with this sort of crazy line where
black can simplify
and find a draw instead we see the move
d4
by wesley or by magnus carlsen
and this move does in fact lose how does
this move loose
well due to the unfortunate placement of
black's pieces
once again the idea of the exchange
sacrifice comes into play
and rook f1 is just going to be the move
i i guess it's not really even an
exchange sacrifice
uh the point is just that this bishop's
pinned
and this is absolutely doomed for uh for
black
okay so rook f1 is the idea magnus tries
to stay in the game
with this little tactic but this is not
going to be good enough
bishop takes c6 and unlike rook and
games which are always drawn
bishop and games are sadly not always
drawn
and this is one of those ones that is
just not
going to be drawn why not well this a
pawn is just too strong
and is queening on a light square the
same color as the bishops
so white is just easily able to evict
this bishop from the diagonal and queen
the pawn
the game continued with b5 bishop d7 a6
takes takes d3 bishop takes d3
uh i don't know why this was included
but it was bishop e5
now a7 bishop c6 and after bishop f1
magnus carlsen threw in the towel and
resigned the game
why resigns here well bishop g2 is the
threat and it's just impossible to stop
the king is not going to be in time
to catch the pawn
or the king is not going to be in time
to catch the pawn
and that's the end of the game so what
happened in these two games
well exactly what i just showed you
happened uh magnus
had a great idea in the first game with
this bishop b4 bishop back to f8
just a reminder that game went knight d2
e6
knight b3 um h6
now knight f3 sorry is this how the game
went
all right i'm just going to flip 2x my
memory is too bad that game went
um knight d2 here e6 knight p3
first knight d7 then knight f3 then h6
bishop b2
and then a5 a4 and here magnus had this
great idea to go bishop b4 check
bishop back to f8 drawing this pawn out
to c3
and because of that wesley got into a
difficult position and ended up losing
the game
and then in this game they went down a
very similar line but wesley first
castles this
king steps his way out of the idea
of bishop b4 check and only then
goes for this knight d2 to b3 idea
and ends up winning so questions on
these two games this was sort of the the
meat of the lecture
that i wanted to uh to talk about here
today questions on these two games
hello long time no see it's been two
whole days
two whole days
the chat is mad at me for touching my
face sorry i can't help it
can't help it it's unconscious even when
people are thinking about it and
actively trying not to do it they still
do
and my nose was itchy what can i do man
well i just did it again i'm the worst
would it help if i said i washed my
hands before
ah pivot trick missed the stream i did
not get another haircut
is it always a good idea for black to
play in early a5
well this game would be the sort of
counter argument to that
right uh black actually loses this game
because a5
was an attackable weakness so
perhaps a5 is a double-edged idea
in the first game it worked very well
for magnus because it
sort of inhibited blacks or white's play
on the queen side entirely thanks to
this bishop before idea
in this game sort of just gave white
another target on the a5 square
and a5 wasn't necessarily forced by
black you very much can just continue
with the move like knight d7
but now white's idea is going to be to
still take away this b6 square from
from the black pieces but that being
said
there are actually a ton of games from
this position and perhaps this is why
we don't see black playing a5 in this
exact position
so often here i think wesley just found
the great way
to to refute it
uh okay well with that we have about 10
minutes left
why don't we take a look at one more
game and this
is going to be the one that wesley's so
uh
did win i believe in the main match
that last game was from the tiebreak
that was sort of the decisive game that
gave
wesley the victory but here's how wesley
battled back in the main match after
losing that one game
in the caro con 2 magnus we had d4
knight of six i'm going to go through
this one pretty quickly as we are a bit
short on time
we end up with the queen's gambit
declined with all of the knights being
developed
this is sort of the one of the most
common positions you'll reach in the qgd
generally people aren't so happy about
the nimzo unless they've seen
my eight lectures on the f3 nimzo and
how to beat black in every variation
so white oftentimes plays knight f3 to
avoid this line
then black relents and goes into a qgd
and only then will white develop this
bishop
or this knight out to uh to c3 and here
wesley plays c5 and this is the the
semi-triash or maybe just
the actual terrace depending on who you
ask i think it's the semi-trash because
we developed this night
and this is sort of the the most uh
sort of challenging way uh that black
can play in this opening
what do i mean by that well with c5
black of course
increases the tension in the center sort
of the maximum
and is basically saying black is
basically saying i
am going to equalize right now i'm
having
no more of this opening garbage where we
both develop our pieces and i have less
space
i'm playing c5 i am meeting you on the
center
uh at the center of the board right at
the front lines
i am conceding no ground to you and we
will be playing on level footing so now
the onus is really
on white to prove something rather
immediately
or else if you just play perhaps a slow
move like e3
the the tension may continue to hold and
eventually
we're gonna see that black is able to
either equalize or at least get into
pretty reasonable iqp positions here
right this would be an example where
white has still a little bit more space
but uh is also settled with a weakness
and black tends to score well here
and just for example if you play a move
like bishop e2
then for example dc4 bishop c4
c takes d4 and if you play something
like knight takes d4
you're sort of in danger of being worse
with white already
so c5 an equalizing attempt and there's
sort of two ways to play against it
number one you can keep the tension in
the center for as long as possible
but then you run the risk of black uh
sort of resolving the tension in a
favorable manner
or you can do what magnus does which is
just all right fine i'll i'll just take
everything and we'll figure it out
so c takes d5 uh is uh
magnus's choice and now black can either
play knight takes d5 or the move in the
game
c takes d4 we see queen takes d4 by
magnus now e takes d5 and it is actually
black with the iqp
and here rather than just play a slow uh
game against the isolated queen's pawn
magnus perhaps taking into account the
match situation in that he only needs to
draw out in order to win
plays the move e4 and goes for a very
simplified type of position after d
takes e
queen takes d8 king takes d8 and knight
g5
this bishop comes to e6 and now it's
true that white could perhaps regain the
pawn
with knight take c4 but instead magnus
perhaps plays for more with knight takes
e6
and this is the generally the move that
players with the white pieces
uh just play in this position my
database shows they've gotten here 16
times
and all 16 times this was played and
now when i was like looking around
clicking around at all these other games
generally they all end up going the same
way
and that way is bishop g5 pinning the
knight to the king
knight takes e4 regaining the pawn and
then white tries to be slightly better
with the two bishops and what we're
going gonna see in the game
is that magnus just has a very strange
aversion to to capturing this pawn
magnus just didn't want to capture this
pawn and then wesley
was able to win because he had more
pawns uh
it was sort of really strange to see in
my opinion
he starts with with bishop c4 which is a
perfectly fine move
it draws this king out to e7 no other
way really to defend this pawn
playing e5 would be asking a little bit
too much i think
you give up the d5 square and this pawn
itself is
is also not going to be super happy here
this bishop is however going to be super
happy so king e7 instead
we see kingside castles by magnus now
knight bd7
rook d1 by magnus again just making no
attempt at all to take this pawn back
on e4 we see rook c8 by
uh wesley so now this bishop drops back
to c2
and black plays a6 and i want to sort of
highlight this move
because it's the move that really strong
players play
it's also the move that really weak
players play like this comment was
actually made in the previous game about
magnus playing h6 at some point
so why does wesley play a6 here well
you get down to the lines and you
realize
that a lot of the time in these these
types of positions where black is a
little bit behind
in development it's so so critically
important that a piece doesn't land on
b5
at the wrong moment like you are two
moves away from a knight being on d6
and a lot of the time it's really really
worth it to play a6
just to keep this knight out of the game
now when is it not worth it well
it's not worth it if knight b5 is sort
of an empty threat if there's nothing
happening after knight b5
but uh it's also not worth it of course
if you're like losing in the center of
the board if
white is doing things on the other side
or in the center then moves like a6
definitely aren't called for
but in general knight b5 can be a really
dangerous idea
in these types of qgd queen queen's
gambit positions
where the c and d files have been opened
just want to mention that
in general be on the lookout for knight
b5 ideas and be aware that a6
can be a good response and now magnus
plays bishop e3 and this is sort of the
move that that takes it over the edge
for me this
uh technically isn't the the inaccuracy
that gives black the advantage
but this is the move that i think shows
that magnus is just in the wrong frame
of mind
for this position i think in magnus's
mind look at these bishops
they're great my position's great i'm
doing so so well
who cares about a double e pawn i have
that blockaded anyways but
i think really the correct way to look
at this position is
okay yeah i have two bishops but i'm
down a pawn
right i am down a pawn and the move
bishop g5 i think
just really really very much is is
called for here
you have to take this pawn back at some
point um
for example in the game bishop e3 rook
c6 was played
another just improving move by wesley so
keeping track of this e6 pawn as well
before trying
to go about the business of developing
this bishop
uh rook a to c1 and now king d8 is
played and perhaps this shows that
bishop c4
was a good inclusion by magnus to draw
this king out here and then have it
retreat
later on and now bishop d4
and again i think this is just a little
bit too nonchalant
by magnus carlsen once again you need to
go bishop g5
and you need to take this pawn back this
is something that you have to do
otherwise you're down a pawn and pawns
are good
like i don't get it magnus what are you
doing pawns are just too strong
for example uh if black were to try
something like h6
simplest for white is just to take this
and take this back and not be worse
maybe maybe maybe be slightly better
because this e6 pawn can be a little bit
weak sometimes
and if you try king e8 to keep
everything well now this is a little bit
too much for example knight a4
opens the c file and this rook is going
to be able to invade
to some some nasty squares so what
happens in the game
well in the game magnus plays bishop d
d4
and this allows black to just develop
with the move bishop d6 perhaps
this is also the hidden reason behind
the move
rook to c6 why is bishop d6
such a critically important move well
now in all those lines that we just
looked at
where net a4 happens and there's an
active rook on the c file
black is ready to defend the c7 square
play king e7
defending the c8 square and sort of just
consolidate entirely and that's what
wesley so does
and after he finishes consolidating an
extra pawn is an extra pawn
even if you do have the bishop pair so
knight a4
was played in the game this was still
the right idea we see rook c1 rook c1
and now king e7 and all of a sudden all
of black's pieces are in the game
all the knights are on reasonable
squares the bishop on d6 is a powerful
piece
and this rook is is sort of next on the
agenda how do you
stop this rook from coming into the game
for example on the d file
and the answer is you can't so at the
end of the day
magnus carlsen just down a pawn that's
that's all
and that was the story of the game uh
the game did continue
uh pretty naturally wesley brings this
knight out to d5
and then as we do run out of time i do
just want to sort of fast forward
because the heart of the game is
is over wesley has the extra pawn and is
just going about the business of
converting it now
knight d3 by the way really nice move
not afraid to bring this pawn
to the super far advanced square on d3
keeping in mind that the simpler the end
game the more powerful the kings and
wesley so's king
is much closer to the action than
magnus's
so b3 played instead now king d6
king activity is important f3 knight
back to c5 defending and attacking
fe4 knight e4 now e5 and it's no longer
a doubled extra pawn it's just a pure
extra pawn
and here knight c3 and lookout
this pawn is coming down the board
b5 king up to e3
and the conversion is almost
over as we see in the pure end game
wesley just has more pawns it's that
simple guys
extra pawn is good the extra pawn is now
an extra two and
this is just going to be impossible to
stop
magnus carlsen resigned in this position
and had a
reasonably bad birthday i'm willing to
wager losing
the skilling open uh to wesley so so
very impressive stuff by both players
here today as i switch back
to my full camera view now i switch back
to the intro
now i switch back to the full camera
view uh
really interesting stuff by both players
i really really enjoyed especially those
two games in the carol khan
where we saw this battle of ideas we saw
wesley so
finding the improvement and proving why
a5 is not such a common move
and we saw then in that last game we
covered for for the 10 minutes
uh we we saw wesley winning with an
extra pawn it's as simple as that
wesley had an extra pawn in the opening
magnus didn't take it back
and then wesley so just converted with
ease as he so often does
if you guys are watching live please
stay tuned we do have the
end game class on youtube pip and chuck
not on twitch yet that comes after
uh so we'll still be right here on
youtube with the end game class
uh and i'm gonna go over more more rook
end games aren't aren't we all so happy
that this rook
end game theme is just never going to
die i could talk about rook end games
for the next three years
and not run out of material so we're
going to do more rook end games
on the end game class directly following
this with all that being said
thank you all so much for watching as
always
my name is caleb denby and i will see
you
next time
you